Oh there it goes oh
Wow
You know when it comes to experimenting often the devil is in the details
And there's a little small minute detail to make all the difference in the kind of results you get so for this video
We're back in the lab with our vacuum chamber and a bunch of water balloons to see if this time we can actually make them
Explode now the last time I tried putting water balloons in a vacuum chamber
I fully expected that once we drew a vacuum those water balloons would start boiling and expand to the point where they'd ruptured but in
Fact that didn't happen at all the balloons just sat there and was really anti-climatic
It was really surprising to me that the water didn't boil and the balloon didn't change shape at all
But I'm pretty sure the results in this
Experiment are going to be a little bit different because shortly after I put out that video our friends is the action lab reached out
With a suggestion. They suggested that the problem was we had our balloons filled with cold water if we use hot water it probably would have worked
So here's the premise of our experiment were going to start off the very first test with a cold water balloon
And we're going to position the neck of the water balloons facing upward so we can push all the air out
Before we tie it off. We don't want to have any air inside these balloons whatsoever now based on our last experiment
I'm expecting cold water will have no effect the balloon will basically just sit there at the same time
We're going to fill up another water balloon with hot water straight from the tap and place them side-by-side
And what do you predict is going to happen are the balloons going to stay the same well?
They both inflate well one infalte
And the other doesn't put your predictions in the comments below let's see if you're right
the other question on my mind is doesn't matter how hot the water is like can we use hot water right from the tap or
Do we need to boil it on the stove?
Obviously hot water from the tap isn't going to be nearly as hot as near boiling water, but will it still work?
Let's go put that to the test right now by now
We got cold water first
Now it's important to note neither of these balloons actually have any air in them
We held them up right we squirted all the air out so any
Growing any bubbling anything that happens inside these balloons will actually be because of the difference in the vapor pressure inside the balloon itself
This one is cold this one is hot let's see if our friends the action lab are right and see if it makes any kind
of difference at all in they go
perfect Lid goes on vacuum pump begins
You can actually see the pink one growing a little bit
Oh, there it goes. Oh wow
sweet
Alright cool. Let's turn that off and talk about what just happened
Did you see that did you see the difference the blue water balloon?
Did absolutely nothing it just stayed there in place kept its shape but the pink water balloon on the other hand
Started growing and then boom hit this point of no return where it expanded tremendously
hung out for a few seconds and then
Exploded and as soon as it did you can see all the water in the bottom was boiling profusely now
I still got this under vacuum
You can see there's a lot of mist in there, so if we go ahead and release the pressure let's see what happens
There's water everywhere, but it essentially clears the cloud and our cold water balloon is
Exactly as we put it in so yes
I think that lends credibility to the idea that hot water balloons will explode in a vacuum and not only that
They explode with power and prestes knew what this makes you want to do
Blow it up. A whole bunch more if you can you do it again
clean up
All right here we go with round two
I got three more hot water balloons
And I made these ones different sizes just so we can find out whether size makes a difference. Let's drop them in and find out
Alright, Lid is on vacuum engaged
crazy crazy, okay let me talk about that first a second so observing this thing from a distance
I noticed the orange balloon did start to grow first
And then very quickly was followed by the yellow balloon now there was a short burst where the yellow balloon and started to grow a little
Bit faster, but they eventually caught up
and then when the green one started to filling up they all got jammed in the container together and then everything seemed to stop for
A second until the orange balloon popped suddenly and did you notice what happened when it did?
As soon as the orange balloon popped in all the water rushed out the other balloons began to shrink back down. That's
interesting the reason I think that happened is because the vapor pressure of the water now in the container was less than that in the
Balloon and so the vacuum was sucking that vapor first so theoretically if we dump the excess water out of this container and turn it
Back on we should be able to get that yellow and green balloon to pop as well
Let's see if that's really the case here we go
Yeah, so you look at all that water in there right now all that water just floating around free is the reason those other balloons
Won't expand if we get rid of that. I'm pretty confident. We can get the other ones to explode
So I've just dumped out the water these balloons. Aren't nearly as warm as they used to be however. They are still warm enough
I think let's find out
They're going to stop it right there for a second because obviously there's still a little water in there
And it's fighting against that water vaporizing off the bottom and the water in the balloon
So I'm actually gonna dry it with the paper towel make sure it's Crystal clean to see if that makes a difference
Love the way that shrink back down
boom
Okay, you know what it is these balloons
Have actually cooled down so much that they're not
Expanding as quickly as we wanted to hear so I'm going to start a fresh batch with warmer balloons
So you get that pop reaction we're looking for
Yeah, if I feel these balloons now they've cooled down quite a bit I
Mean this one's really like just room temperature this one's slightly warm
We are seeing them expanding but these aren't hot balloons anymore. It's cooled down quite a bit
I'm going to make up two new balloons with nice hot water same sizes
We'll see how they do all right back to new balloons this time warm water
Relatively warm makes my cheeks tingle, so let's put them in watch them grow
Cool very cool
All right guys well
I think that pretty much proves that hot water balloons in a vacuum chamber behaves much differently than cold water in a vacuum chamber here's
Why I think that happens the elastic resistance of the water balloons creates its own pressure and almost acts like its own atmosphere
Inside the balloon now the vapor pressure of water in Standard atmosphere has to overcome
14.7 PsI at sea level for it to actually vaporize
That's why if we create a vacuum and reduce that pressure it'll boil at much lower temperatures
But the opposite is true when inside a balloon
it's almost like putting a balloon over the whole Earth and
Compressing the atmosphere which means the temperature would have to be much higher to get it to boil and once the balloon
Begins to Expand the pressure inside is already less which accelerates the reaction rapidly until the balloon is so enormous the skin ruptures
So guys we learn something new we learned a bit more about
Atmospheric pressure vapor pressure of water itself and some of the difference of how cold water reacts VS
The hot water to stuff and of course a big thanks to our friends at the action lab for reaching out with this solution
You go ahead and check your youtube inbox. I'm sending in 25 bucks. Thanks for joining us for this experiment today
We'll be looking for the next one. Talk to you then oh
Wow
Apparently putting balloons with water in the microwave makes them explode as well
Oh, yeah, look how fast that goes that's amazing
Dang, I was only like five seconds the whole thing went from nothing to eruption
Hey guys, there is an event called CVx live that. I'm going to be at august 3rd through 5th stage presentations meet and greets
There's even a special superfan experience where we can hang out one-on-one
So click the link in the description and I'll be looking for you at CVX live